warriors and hunters wizards and priests
long now have your four classes lived
together as one and how they have
flourished where once stood only a few
marriott's now looms a glorious city of
iron and steel trade and commerce music
and laughter a place called ardent I've
been watching you this many years have
seen the sparks from your anvils fly
have observed your Gardens blossom and
your life stocks well I've heard the
spinning of your ever busy looms and
have listened to the Quattro mighty
timber fell your bountiful villages have
multiplied as have the feats of your
brain eros men and women who have
valiantly explore terrifying and
wondrous new lands together you have
battled ghoulish fiends and defeated
nightmarish beasts several of which were
the very last of relics wound of horrors
I'm afraid though that not quite all of
Malik's clan has been extinguished I
know one member who was patiently bided
his time deep within a fortress of stone
Shh can you not hear it of course you
can't vanity and self-indulgence are
surely dulled your senses so put down
your pies and ales and listen now that
is the sound of truth unity the gates
Carson Tyrell have been flung wide and a
thousand soldiers cut from unbreakable
stone March for they have been given one
directive to crush ardent just as your
four elders slew my master when he was
at the height of his power so to where I
destroy your glorious city and all those
who helped to build it how ignorant you
all are to think that I would have let
the death of Malik go unpunished well
that I have merely SAT idly by these
many years you need only venture inside
my impenetrable mountain to find that I
rule an entire kingdom old beasts you
thought long dead I found a home with me
while new creatures are daily forged
from the heart of the mountain I have
been amassing an army for decades and
now at last my avalanche of stone has
been released
all will be crushed and I will have my
vengeance
i am lord pyrus